[Music]
we're ending america's longest war
20 years
it's obviously not a success
[Music]
we knew we were there to evacuate the
at-risk afghans
the u.s citizens they kind of made it
sound like oh it's going to be quick and
simple we're going to be in and out
but that didn't happen here
[Music]
[Applause]
it was very dark times in afghanistan
when taliban took over
i was tell that if you do not leave in
the coming three days
you will be assassinated
we've got thousands of people panicked
the runway was the mission keep the
runway open at all costs
in a
month the government had collapsed the
afghan president was gone i'm being told
hey we're working with the taliban now
[Music]
our mission was to not let anyone to
leave the country
the situation on the ground is something
like i've never experienced before in
any of my deployments
everyone was moving toward the airport
you never want to tell your man you
don't know what to do
i had no idea what to do
please let us like just get out of here
you leave a place where you never think
you leave
together
but you leave it because you can't live
you